[Music]
[Applause]
all the popular mike chorico nbc uh
football night in america and serious xm
masters play-by-play joining us on the
program mike good morning how are you
dp how are you i'm good the biggest is
that uh is that your master's green
sweatshirt hoodie that you're wearing
today
it's uh no
i i was trying to go with a little
master's green
but it's a different shade
do you remember
back at the mother ship
when boomer
would do baseball tonight on the sunday
night of the masters and wear his green
jacket oh my god
and he spent a lot of money on that
green jacket he was right chris berman
was really proud of those jackets
because he never wore a suit he'd always
have a sport coat and and he'd have his
dockers on
but always had his green jacket
i do remember
the jacket
the difference in doing radio and tv at
augusta biggest difference is what
so i only did radio in 2019 before and
uh they asked me to come back uh for
this year and i got to work with curtis
strange which was fun it's my old
partner um you know it's so
in
usually golf you're trying to stay quiet
people can watch what's happening uh but
you're trying to describe the holes
you're just describing what the players
are wearing you're trying to read the
shot shape of the ball in the air all
that stuff there's a great group uh
siriusxm
uh they do the pga tour radio almost
every week and most of those individuals
were on the masters coverage they do
such a good job so just try not to screw
it up and just try to spin it with other
folks but
you know somebody said to me why are you
gonna do radio well only two people get
to call the masters jim does obviously
with cbs jim nance and if you get to do
radio why not if you love golf and you
love calling golf
be a part of history you know from your
times there anytime you can be
associated with the masters it's a great
sense of pride it's also a great
experience in your career so i was happy
to do it it was a blast a great great
group of people to work with and who
decides where you go i know in a tv
broadcast you know they're going to say
you're on this one in you know and we're
going to then go to 14 after this
uh how do you
kind of navigate
good question same kind of deal uh
because there were announcers almost at
every set of holes like an announcer at
amen corner announcer 15 16 it was
bouncing around so we would do
8 9 10 14 and 18 with me and curtis in
the main broadcast position and then
went out to 18 and it was kind of fun
because going out to 18 you're 25 yards
away from the hole
so you are in full announce golf
announcer whisper mode which doesn't
happen much anymore because the the
towers as they're constructed are now
covered with sound proofing and all that
but here it's open top and you're just
covered by a little plexiglass so you're
in full he has this now to win the
masters
oh my god look at me i'm a meme of
myself an audio meme of myself but
it was great and great to be there to
see scotty scheffler finish that off
what a really cool run he's had and it's
no fault of scotty's but it felt like
there was a letdown of sorts because
tiger kind of had he put down the
breadcrumbs and we're like oh man this
is awesome yeah he's under par
he made the cut now he gets to the
weekend this is when tiger he's going to
wear red on sunday he's going to be
there and then all of a sudden you
realize that
he became a mere mortal like we probably
uh expected him to do after those first
couple of rounds at what point did you
think
what we saw is not what we're going to
continue to see with tiger
yeah later on on friday afternoon you
know uh it was funny we were talking
about why does tiger do this why is this
impact well it's hard to quantify it's
so many different reasons but here we
are on tuesday morning and wednesday
morning i'm on the today show noted the
gaze on the today show scott van pelt on
good morning america uh dana jacobson
was there for cbs it it became
larger than sports which the masters
often is it's the one golf event that
jumps a little bit above the radar but
he's the one guy who takes it to another
level and you saw that and we're on the
air on golf central on golf channel on
thursday tigers tigers even power tigers
one under par he's got a punch to tie
for the lead on thursday and you're
going wow this is crazy because it was
given where he was and dan given that
his camp
was really shocked if you would have
asked on march 1st do you think tiger's
going to play the masters most around
him would have said no so this came on
uh pretty quickly for the people who
were in the know there uh but i think by
friday he started to realize that he
can't drive it where the other guys were
and you could see him laboring a little
bit and then saturday sunday i think the
wear and tear of that
plus not being in competition as much as
he has been tiger was best at grinding
out a par he just couldn't do that on
saturday and sunday
and he responded to you know the patrons
rooting him on when he would have a bad
hole
and and that helped him because he's so
used to hearing the roars he's done
something well
and you know tiger doesn't want to be
embarrassed out there tigers out there
to win and then it felt like you're on a
ride that you don't want to be on but
you got to see it to the very end and
you know you kind of walk away and you
know kind of take inventory and now he's
going to play uh you know in the british
open at saint andrews so i thought the
win was him getting there mike i thought
that that was
a thousand yeah
dan i'm totally with you and uh you know
we've sat in the chair working with
analysts and we'll often look at them
and say
what do you take away from that round
well what i took away from tigers first
round
was that word of appreciation and
gratitude you heard that a lot this week
but as i said on the air i've never seen
tiger shoot 71 and smile the way he was
smiling when he came off the golf course
on thursday which gave you a sense that
only he knew
what he did and how hard he had to work
to get to thursday and same thing for
tiger to shoot
the two highest scores he's ever shot at
augusta in a tournament 78 78 over the
weekend
and walk off that 18th green with that
world famous recognizable ear to ear
toothy smile
that
tells you
what it meant for him to get there to
play to make the cut and to finish 72
holes tiger was never about that
and i think he allowed himself to take
in more of the appreciation from the
people around him than ever before and
if the mountain was as high as we
believe when you're talking about
potentially having your leg removed and
amputated
13 months later you're playing on a
tough as you know a tough golf course to
walk and you do it for four days
then he should be really proud of what
he did we're talking to mike trico who
is also the voice of sunday night
football his wildest offseason that i
can remember mike um do you guys know
what your opening night game is going to
be or
do you have an idea of who you think
it's going to be
an idea but i certainly think we don't
know these things are so changeable as
as you know you would hope and imagine
that the champs are somewhere in there
the rams will do that whether it's
thursday or sunday in in week one that
has become the tradition in the league
so you would hope that would happen but
uh i think we're all anxiously oh
certainly i'm anxiously looking forward
to may to find out where we're going to
be to start the season and you know all
the places will go and i think dan
with so many good teams this might be a
really interesting year with flexing
to games on the sunday night schedule
but let me give you the afc this way
right a lot of people say who's the best
team in the afc
so start going division by division who
are the teams the afc that you think
can't make the playoffs
and when you go through that list right
now
here in april
it's three maybe four
that tells you that the afc is going to
be wide open as the year goes on
health when you play people how healthy
you are when you play people that's
going to go a long way i bet you they're
going to be four or five teams right now
who think they're going to make the
playoffs and then after the draft of
course you think you're going to make
the playoffs who aren't going to in the
afc and i think it's going to be a real
fight for those spots this year i really
do and i mentioned this a couple of
times to my audience you know it wasn't
that long ago when russell wilson was a
seahawk brady was retired aaron rodgers
future
was in doubt carson wentz a cold
devontae adams a packer calvin ridley
was still active khalil mack was a bear
von miller was a free agent mitchell
trubisky was in buffalo troy aikman and
joe buck were with fox and deshawn
watson was preparing for a grand jury
and bruce arians uh was still the head
coach
that was march mike
i know i know right and we're only at
april 11th we've got the draft and some
trades probably somewhere around there
too and all these teams with multiple
picks some people deal with a pick to
get to next year people dealing picks to
get to the value part of this draft 30
to 50 or 60 and we're going to see good
players come out of there we always do
the nfl you talk about how tiger takes
the spotlight and attention when he's in
the golf tournament when the nfl makes
news it just takes all the attention
away from everything else and and
it has become the biggest entertainment
vehicle in america it gathers people it
connects people walking around augusta
just seeing people and saying hi do you
think my bills have a chance this year
do you think we'll get a sunday night
home game this year i mean this is just
random and people talk about the jaguars
hey do you like their free agent
assignments like i think they can be
pretty good everybody has
an unbelievable bizarre nature of
i guess over hyped hope
with the free agency and draft moves you
think
we're one or two teams or two moves away
hey you know what dan and you you know
because it's a team close to your heart
look at the bengals this year
were you thinking this time last year
not only would the bengals be a super
bowl team but a team that you were
really looking forward to watching the
following year and for a few years to
come
no
and that's why
i think the nfl has this magnetism
because everybody's a two chess move
away from
we can be really good situation i love
that about the league right now and i
don't know of another sport
uh
where you have that hope that optimism
when you go to spring training or
it's the nba you know the orlando magic
fans don't go this could be our year or
uh you know throw out even somebody like
pittsburgh pirates you know you might
might get be a playoff team but the nfl
allows you to actually dream you know
there are certain fan bases that
probably go let's be realistic here
we're lions fans or
you know we're jags fans but everybody
else you go if the bengals can do it why
can't we
and jags and lions fans are saying the
same thing now right okay we've got
trevor lawrence we're we've acquired a
bunch of players have some draft picks
where are the lions well guess what you
go back and watch the last half dozen
games in chris collinsworth and i would
talk about this a few weeks ago go back
and watch the last four or five games
the lions gave people a real headache
they played hard and the whole bike the
kneecaps thing etc with dan campbell
they played hard and i love the fact
that they're on hard knocks because
people are going to see what they're
building and that may make it attractive
to other and all of a sudden you're a
quarterback or you're a couple of
skilled players a game changer on
defense
away in a division that after aaron
rodgers and the packers you can contend
pretty quickly so there is that hope
whereas like you said and i'll just stay
with where i live with in detroit with
the tigers reference um for the last
couple of years the detroit tigers had
no chance
this year the guys who they drafted
number one guys like uh spencer
torkelson and riley green they're now
coming up to the big club although green
got hurt at the end of uh of spring
training but they went out and acquired
javi baez they acquired some veterans
and now
the tigers have a chance they have a
chance to be a playoff contending team
but it took three years to build that or
four years so you're right the nfl it
happens like this the other sports it
takes a while and let's think about our
society people want instant they want
microwave fast quick
and that may be part of the subliminal
appeal to the year-round
run that the nfl always seems to get
nfl's undefeated mike
that's exactly right no matter how hard
sometimes yeah how hard sometimes it
tries it wins every game but i wonder
though the sport you know it dwarfs
everything and now it's dwarfing you
know march madness you know that was
during march that you had all those
stories right that's what i wonder about
with these other sports being collateral
damage because the nfl is so big i can
turn on any show this morning
and they're probably trying to find an
nfl story to talk about instead of
frank vogel getting fired or scottie
scheffler winning the masters
right is scottie sheffler the next great
golfers one four times in eight weeks uh
look at our conversation right here
right it's kind of it it reverts back
because
it always feels like there's something
you're interested in hearing about even
the mba i think the super teams and the
movement in many regards has not allowed
teams to build and get familiar with and
guys move around and with the 82 game
schedule you lose that passion like i
remember being so excited to see what
are the playoff matchups what's going to
be the late afternoon game on abc on
saturday how the series gonna match up
and i peaked just this morning okay well
denver golden state that's a heck of a
first round series i'm looking forward
to that
i want to see if giannis and milwaukee
can i want to see how real phoenix was
what they learned from last year
but there's not that same feeling for 12
months it's just now because we're
getting to the runway where the nba
takes off and a lot of us who weren't
spending all the time on the 82 games
dial in for six weeks with the nfl it's
12 months for 17 games which is pretty
remarkable steve kerr said he was asked
about how do you
maybe encourage teams to play their
players stars more games and he said why
don't we go to 72 games
do you think that that would fly that
more players would play in more games
because we're taking 10 regular season
games off the schedule
no i think we're trying to just get
everybody to where they need
they're needed the most right so
maybe if you went to 60 games and it
really became a challenge to make the
playoffs but as you know there are so
many reasons you can't do that live gate
tickets building availability because so
many of these teams have a piece if not
the entirety of ownership of their
building
local and regional sports networks
streaming all of that stuff how are you
going to make all the streaming money
and the regional sports networks trying
to earn their money back for their
investment so you need the content but i
think look why is the nfl so valuable
because it's only 16 games and in a
month you're through 25 of your season
where it's half that in the nba or third
of that
less than that in the nba and the nhl
and major league baseball's much less
than that right so what happens one
night two nights is not a big deal you'd
have to i think shrink the number even
more than 72 and now you start messing
with historical and all that stuff so um
it makes sense it would be nice if it
happens but in reality does that work on
the financial side of the business and
let's forget that this is commerce this
is capitalism this is business at the
end of the day good to talk to you as
always thanks for joining us stay here
pal thank you any time bishop that's uh
mike trico sunday night football
play-by-play taken over for al michaels
and uh was on the call on siriusxm at
the masters well